[Music]  thank you  [Music]  this is for you oh Sean yes please that  is yours no I I feel terrible outside I  just it's just the symbolic silly thing  yes but I if I know but if I know this  is here with you then I'll then I'll  feel better and stronger for the fight  so brave brain to honor but but until we  will when you when you win bring it back  to Malibu right right okay because I'll  feel much better knowing there's a piece  of me here  [Music]  a moment which is very important it's  not for me it's from Ukraine and it's  more important  for me  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  if you don't know this guy that is a  great honor today  there are three places in the world that  all the pride of my life will be the  place where my daughter was born  a place where my son was born on this  thank you thank you so much thank you so  much  thank you I really appreciate it thank  you no we we thank you we thank you very  much